highlight nicht schon wieder dieses
verpackte hohe alter hallo mein name ist
dukan herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen videos habe euch mal wieder
bei twitter gesagt hey leute postet mit
witz unter dem hashtag luca reagiert
irgendwelche videos fragen keine ahnung
was ihn dann reagiere ich darauf wurden
meine damen und herren jetzt bis dieser
moment gekommen
warum kündigt das so episch an das
format ist eben schätzen wir starten
direkt hier rein in diese folge mit dem
video wo jemand mit einem kopfball
ein motiv hängt da muss ich wirklich
sagen das ist content auf wenig gewartet
hat aber man muss wirklich sagen da wird
zumindest mal schnitt gesetzt das haben
wir hier ist wirklich selten welche
zuschauer videos darauf reagiere ich
grad weihnachten und an die person die
mir das zu gesendet hat wenn ich immer
so zum zeitpunkt der aufnahme den
kalender schaue sehe ich okay es ist der
fünfzehnte mehr als heute waren 17 grad
in köln es war ultra besonnen brachten
und sie kommen wird dass das verstehe
ich nicht
gegen wie in die bis zu drei monate zu
spät
[Musik]
das was ich jetzt sagen werde ist kein
produkt placement oder irgendwie
gesponsert oder keine ahnung was aber
ich habe früher nur bomber ketchup
gegessen
das waren das waren meine absoluten
lieblings chips mittlerweile als ich die
gar nicht mehr so sehr weil für mich
waren bomben immer so kinder chips die
hände teddybären formen und keine ahnung
was mir meine freundin mal so gesagt
jawohl okadas
chips mit ketchup du ist doch auch nicht
eine spaghetti mit backsteinen oder
sowas aber hey pomberg edge ob ich hab
die komplett geliebt also meine frage zu
beantworten ja ich kenne bombeck
headshop und allgemein war kurz diesem
kompletten format lokal geht doch videos
von euch mir wird oft vorgeworfen ich
liebe wirklich nur bis heute videos 93
das liegt daran dass wirklich 99%
bescheuert sind aber ich finde das macht
dieses format ja auch so ein bisschen
haus und ich versuche jetzt wirklich
gezielt demnächst mehr fragen zu nehmen
aber ich würde sagen wir mal ehrlich wer
mit dem nächsten video da sich diese
einblendung beschreibt komplett mein
leben und meine beziehung zu meinen
freunden nämlich ich komme dann immer so
an hallo mein name ist lukas als mal
[Musik]
auch hier wieder einen vollen heißes
video das wir zugesandt wurde wirklich
einfach ein zug der den leipziger
hauptbahnhof einfährt ich meine freunde
das ist wirklich content
dafür hat ihm einen kanal abonniert wie
ich als kompletter vollhorst auf videos
reagiere wo ein zug in einem bahnhof
einfährt
also ich meine warum sonst sollte man
youtube abonniert haben außer dass sie
auf züge den hauptbahnhof einfahren
reagieren sagt mir dass man leute lasst
man leichter wenn ihr findet das dass
das hier wirklich das beste format auf
youtube es hat also hier kann man den
ich noch was lernen sie hat in dem
schmied dazu geschrieben dass ich das
ganze mal nachmachen soll
gebt mir mal kurz 2000 jahre zeit 2000
jahre später in diesem nächsten video
seht ihr jetzt einen typischen zuschauer
von meinem kanal eingeblendet werden
sich das neueste video von crafter
anschaut
ich liebe meine fans wirklich habe aber
das hat wehgetan immer offenes herz ich
bin super euch zu unterhalten
ich finds auch klasse wie in meinen
videos dann feiert da kommen die
wirklich die tränen ich habe wirklich
gold ich bin gekränkt in meinem ganzen
immer in meinem tiefsten herzen weil ein
warum ok irgendwie kommt mir so vor als
ob es um nach und nach ersetzt werde ich
meine allein jetzt hier die nächste
einblendung ist einfach auch wieder was
wo meine stimme auf etwas animiertes
gepackt wurde also schauen wir uns doch
jetzt mal diese kontraste animation hier
an
was sind das nicht was diese leute die
sie ihr vermögen dahin
das ist mit einer von den besten
animationen die ich je gesehen hat also
wirklich wir wurde in dem tweet gesagt
hey yo luca ich habe eine animation für
dich gemacht die ist haben wir heftig
cool und ich meinen es sei ja auch neues
aus allerdings diese storyline also da
laufe ich langlauf gegen den steinen und
dann sage ich das ist ein verdienst oder
ich habe diese leute die die familie
buchen immer dahin wo das ist das was
ich habe das ausgesprochen was sich
keiner traut auszusprechen könntest du
mein video minuten machen erstmal keine
nachricht an dich ich sah früher genauso
aus wie du spaß
wundert euch nicht wenn du irgendwie 67
jahre älter bist das so so aussieht wie
ich jetzt mal allgemeinen aufs ganze
bezogen ich würde sehr sehr gerne sehr
viel mehr kooperationen mit anderen
youtuber machen die ich selber fahre
aber es liegt an der zeit fall ein wenn
ihr das video hier gerade seht ist ja
wahrscheinlich sonntag der neunzehnte
dritte dass wir gerade in berlin dieses
videos vorproduziert weil ich vier tage
nach berlin muss wegen terminen die ist
das blabla
dann kommt morgen am montag zurück nach
köln dann bin ich drei tage in köln habe
und dann fliege ich am freitag hatte
eine waffe vier tage und danach habe ich
klausuren damit gibt die bachelor zeit
aber ich habe im juli 2017 hatte juli
diese diesen jahres in genau vier
monaten habe ich frei dann bin ich
fertig mit meinem studium hat ein
bachelor abschluss in der tasche
und dann ziehe ich durch mit youtube das
jetzt ist doch gar nichts weil ich so
riesige ankündigung da wir wieder
beschissen highlight
nicht schon wieder dieses verpackte hohe
alter heute mache ich mal einen 100
schichten video 1 100 schichten video
oder schichten video roll und zwar nehme
ich 100 schichten hühner das wird
richtig
das wird richtig aber richtig freut mich
leute wenn ihr dieses video hier feiert
dann schreib doch mal in die kommentare
das ist richtig so um euren support zu
zeigen meine brust immer noch wer auf
einmal smit mit einem video von diesem
verrückten ruhe wo das herkommt in
ladebalken bei dem irgendwie bibi und
julia koan geblendet werden und in so
kurzer zeit trägt
warum aber okay jetzt schauen was war
deine zehn schichten bzw 100 schichten
paar harvey krass ist das bitte stellt
euch mal vor jetzt würde eine bombe
einschlagen
muss ich mir sowas geben leute ich warte
wirklich auf einsendungen leute
irgendwie vierfachen salto machen
irgendwie was was können krass klavier
spielen vielleicht zehn hamburger auf
einmal auf essen oder sohn stattdessen
krieg ich highlight ein sprechendes huhn
anhand dieser einsendung sieht man
wieder wie sehr mich meine zuschauer
wirklich lieben obwohl du deine jetzt
lass ist am morgen um 15 uhr kommen zwei
neue moody's in denen und leute jetzt
nur ganz ganz kurz in werbung für wenn
ihr euch einen von diesen beiden rudy
ist also hier mal kurz zwei bilder von
den beiden ruhiges eingeblendet wenn ihr
euch davon einbestellt morgen um 15 uhr
bekommt ihr definitiv einen signierten
sticker aber nur wenn ihr euch von rudi
kauft also von denen 2000 stück das
heißt schnell
wir machen weiter mit dem videos luca
das bist du und zwar hier kannst du und
deswegen habe ich ihn nach dir benannt
und ja ich verstehe das alles nicht so
diese typischen einsendungen die ich
bekomme ist so ja okay das bist du das
kloster oder nur spaß sie liebt nicht
alles denn der vor allem will ich doch
kein kacken der frosch hey ich bitte
dich
oder hallo luca ich fahre deine videos
so stark immer wenn ich werde das match
so gut geht oder ich schlechte laune
habe dann schaue ich deine videos denn
deine videos haben mir ein lächeln ins
gesicht und hör bitte nicht aus mit
youtube du machst das super und alle
räte sind nur nahe dass das diesen dass
dieses nicht so gut können wie du ich
hab dich lieb jetzt muss ich mal eben
ganz kurz sagen egal wie oft ich
wirklich schon in diesen ganzen
mittlerweile 10 20 videos wo ich auch
zuschauer einsendungen und videos
reagiert habe egal wie oft ich schon
gesagt habe was seid ihr für menschen
machen was macht ihr für ein scheiß ihr
sendet mir kacke ich reagierte darauf es
ist immer noch alles spaß und ich bin
sehr sehr froh dass ich das hier alles
machen darf und ich möchte jetzt gar
nicht zu ihnen
beauty fashion tante werden die sich in
jedem video 40.000 mal so fake bedankt
oder so ich mache das einfach viel zu
selten ich mache ja auch quasi keine
richtigen abos specials aber
ja danke einfach dass ich die
möglichkeit habe sowas zu machen und
dass ihr schwachsinn feiern und sonnen
stumpf gehabt und ich und dass wir das
dass das alles funktioniert und ja ich
mag euch leute ich würde sagen wir
beenden das video mit einer sehr sehr
tollen und bewegenden aussagen
das sollte das lebensmotto von jedem
menschen sein sobald man etwas aus dem
lukas shop hat ist nicht schön wenn sich
das erwachsene leute an gucke ich denke
auch ich bin total bescheuert das was
ihr vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen es getan hat
zum beispiel den daumen nach oben banken
wenn ich das normal machen soll sonst
würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr jetzt
hier auf den smiley darauf klickt dann
könnt ihr nämlich main kanal kostenlos
abonnieren
da umfeld auch meinen shop eingeblendet
und hier unten ist ein anderes video
verlinkt könnt ihr euch gerne angucken
das kann ich schlecht das wetter